Trauma in Afghanistan turmoil in the
Gulf and tension in Hong Kong security
crises haven't stopped because of the
corona virus pandemic instead some
powers are accused of using the Kovach
19 distraction to their own advantage
anyone who wants to get on with things
without the West noticing will be
exploiting this opportunity
let's take Afghanistan
the United States signed a peace deal
with arch foe the Taliban in Qatar in
February just as coronavirus was
infecting the world this should have
been a historic moment of harmony after
almost two decades of war that
withdrawal means that our men and women
in uniform will incur fewer risks our
financial burden will be ease and our
brave troops will return home this is a
hopeful moment but the ink had barely
dried before attacks on us-backed Afghan
forces
again tariffs for civilians to even
babies aren't safe the targeting of a
maternity ward in Kabul a new and brutal
low Special Forces rescue group of
medics holed up in a safer coronavirus
makes it harder for journalists to
report on other crises I'm stuck in the
UK on lockdown but violence in places
like Afghanistan shouldn't be forgotten
the problem there is political as well
the peace deal was supposed to trigger
dialogue between Afghan politicians and
the Taliban insurgents they'd been
fighting but the government has been
consumed by infighting ever since
contested elections last year officials
finally agreed a power-sharing deal in
May unblocking an obstacle to the
Taliban talks expectations for a
breakthrough still low despite the
uncertainty US forces have reduced in
numbers expect violence in Afghanistan
to do the opposite
before coronavirus this threatened to be
the defining crisis of 2020 remember how
the year started with the United States
and Iran on the brink of war it was
triggered by an Iranian backed militia
targeting us-led coalition forces in
Iraq and escalated when the United
States killed top Iranian general Qasem
Soleimani cue an outpouring of grief
rage and then this Iranian missile
strike against US troops no soldier was
killed instead Iran accidentally shot
down a Ukrainian passenger jet as its
air defences braced for a u.s.
counter-attack iran appears to be
standing down which is a good thing for
all parties concerned and a very good
thing for the world in the end donald
trump refrained
but the mutual animosity is as
combustible as ever it's been the case
since President Trump tore up a nuclear
deal with Iran in 2018 he then
re-imposed sanctions targeting Tehran's
oil banking and transport sectors the
move was opposed by key allies including
the UK and it prompted spiraling
tensions in the Gulf
a US spy plane shot down a Saudi oil
refinery ablaze even corona virus which
has hit both countries hard hasn't
changed the fundamentals Iran launched a
military satellite using ballistic
missile technology in April a highly
provocative move expect more fireworks
in October just weeks before the US
elections it's when a UN arms embargo on
Iran expires the u.s. is going all-out
for an extension the problem lies with
the fact that Russia and China are
unlikely to go along as of right now
with any American effort to extend the
arms embargo so this could result in a
showdown at the United Nations Security
Council where one of the two countries
could obstruct an American resolution to
extend the arms embargo
another part of the world to watch is
Hong Kong pro-democracy protests here
dominated headlines before the pandemic
leading activists have since been
arrested but there's new anger after
Beijing passed the security law for the
former British territory China has been
looking for it for a long time to hack
down on the pro-democracy
prohee win rights movements and it seems
to be exploiting the fact that West's
attention is elsewhere to round up a
democracy supporters rest them to put
them on trial trouble - in the South
China Sea ownership of territory in
these waters has been fiercely contested
for centuries it matters because of
natural resources and for control of
important shipping lanes China claims
what it defines as a nine - line
including the Paracel and Spratly
Islands
not so say neighbors Vietnam and the
Philippines the United States accuses
China of using the coronavirus
distraction to tighten its grip Beijing
says that's nonsense
but US warships are increasingly testing
their freedom to maneuver provocative
action against an ever more competent
opponent coronavirus is of course a
crisis for everyone but world leaders
ignore these other major challenges at
their peril
[Applause]